Everyone will have the problem of acne and pimples from the time period of puberty, but do
we know the reason for it? If we
talk about acne or pimples, then
in our skin, a gland is present here,
Sebaceous Gland. What does it do for us?  The
skin secretes oil or sebum to keep it hydrated,
in which some dead cells also come out,
but sometimes what happens is that your skin removes a lot of
dead cells as well and due to
which,  It
is a bacteria, it gets attracted towards our cells,
for this the
WBCs fight you, there the
RBCs become concentrated, due to which
you see a redness, then the
area of ​​acne or pimple is that which is the
base.
gland